[MUSIC PLAYING]
GILAD GOLAN: Hello, everybody.
My name is Gilad Golan.
I'm engineering director for
security and trust in G Suite.
And with me today is Nico.
NICO LIDZBORSKI: Hi,
I'm Nico Lidzborski.
I'm engineering lead for
security and trust on G Suite.
GILAD GOLAN: And
today, we'd like
to talk about email security.
So email-- we love it.
We hate it.
It clogs our inboxes.
It follows us around
on our phones,
but we can't pass
a day without it.
Email has become the
lifeblood of any organization.
So by latest estimates, there
are 3.7 billion email users.
And every day, there are around
269 billion email messages
sent and received.
And what made email so powerful?
So email is universal.
It's open.
It's fast, and it's free.
So think about it.
It's universal,
open, fast, and free.
That's what makes
email so powerful,
but it's also what makes
it the most popular attack
vector for
cyberattacks, which is
why we want to spend
this talk today
discussing email security.
So today, what we're
going to talk about,
we'll discuss some
of the latest threats
that we've been observing
related to email security.
And we'll tell you what
Google does to protect you
against those threats.
And then we'll finish by walking
you through some of the things
that you, as admin,
should do to take
advantage of the
protections that we provide.
So these are the main
email-related threat categories
that we'll discuss today.
So we're going to talk about
spam, phishing, malware,
impersonation and interception.
And we're also going to discuss
email client security and data
loss prevention as
it relates to email.
And we're going to
start with spam,
which is the most common one.
So spam is unsolicited,
irrelevant or inappropriate
messages sent over the
internet to a large number
of recipients.
And we all know it.
We all get it.
We've almost become used to it.
It's mostly commercial
advertising.
It's often for dubious products,
all sorts of "get rich quick"
schemes.
The damage for
organization, it's
mostly waste of time
and productivity loss.
But it does add up.
So over time, it
can be significant.
So what does Google do to
protect you against spam?
And to understand
what Google does,
we need to take a step back and
look at the progress of machine
learning in Google across all
Google products and services.
So today, usage of
machine learning
in all of Google products
has grown exponentially.
And specifically, the latest
developments in deep learning
enable powerful new capabilities
not possible before that.
What you see in this
graph is the number
of deep learning projects
across all of Google products.
So you can see the huge growth
over the last couple of years.
And the progress and the
shared infrastructure
that we build that powers
these innovations across all
of Google, they enable
us-- they give us
capabilities that
seem impossible
only a few years ago.
Just to give you an example
from a familiar product
of the kind of magic that
deep learning provides--
so this is how
Google Photos uses
deep learning models to analyze
photos and to autotag them.
So using machine learning
and deep learning,
Google Photos can analyze
photos like the one
you see on the
left and determine
that this photo should be
tagged by the tag "ocean."
So let's get back to spam now.
We take the similar
kind of magic
that you see in photo tagging
and apply it to spam detection.
So in Google, for
spam detection,
we use what data
scientists call ensemble.
Ensemble is when you take a
number of machine learning
models and use them combined
to achieve higher accuracy.
So what you see in this diagram
is the different models that we
use and the kind of
spam detection accuracy
we achieve with that.
So when you use
them in combination,
we achieve 99.9% accuracy.
And we keep improving it.
So what does it mean?
That means that we have less
than 0.1% false negatives.
This is spam not detected,
adding up in your inboxes.
And we have less than
0.05% false positives.
This is mail by
mistake labeled as spam
and not showing in your inbox.
By the way, the imbalance
that you see between the two
is by design because
false positives
are much more disruptive to
business than false negatives.
So our models are
tuned and optimized
to minimize false positives.
Now let's move on and
talk about phishing.
So phishing is an
attempt to acquire
confidential information
by masquerading
to be a trustworthy
person or organization.
The damage potential of
phishing is much higher.
It can be both financial,
loss of intellectual property,
or damage to reputation.
There is one especially
dangerous variant
of phishing, which
is spearfishing,
which is a targeted
message that appears
to come from a trusted person.
And that trusted person can
be your IT admin or maybe even
your CEO.
Let's look at an example
of a phishing attack.
So a phishing attack
often appears like this--
a very innocent-looking
email message.
In this case, it's directing
you to get some files
from Google Drive.
Now what's interesting
is that often,
the link, the URL
in the message,
it is designed to appear like
a legitimate URL from Google.
You see it's says
host.googledrive.com,
which would make you believe
it's a legitimate Google URL.
Then it goes on--
.service.phish-something
and something.
So it's just a
random URL designed
to look like
something from Google.
And I'm just using
Google as an example.
It could be your bank or
any other organization
that you trust.
Now, if a user clicks
that link, that
will take you to a malicious
clone of a Google sign-in page.
And this can be
designed to be a pixel
by pixel copy of the
real Google sign-in page.
If the user unsuspectingly
enters their credential,
those credentials immediately
go to the attackers.
The attackers can
then immediately
use them to siphon off
sensitive data, which
can happen in seconds.
And after that happens,
the damage is already done.
So what does Google do to
protect you against phishing?
Before we go into the
specific mechanisms,
it's important to understand
that, as in many other cases,
we use a defense in-depth
approach, meaning
we have multiple
layers of defense where
we try to detect and reject
any phishing attacks.
And if they go and pass
through undetected,
we have additional
layers of protection
against those phishing attacks.
So let's look at the--
this is a list of some of
the detection mechanisms
that we have.
So we have a detection
mechanism that
combines both rules written
by security analysts
with machine learning models.
We have a real-time
reputation system,
which is a database maintained
in real-time that covers
domains, links, IP addresses.
And the fact that,
in Gmail, we have
a user base of over a
billion users, that gives us
plenty of early signals
that can help us
maintain the database
up to date in real-time.
And you as enterprise
customers, you
get the benefit
of that database,
which uses the usage pattern
we see from a billion users.
All of these are signals
used for the early detection.
We also do anomaly detection
on the various entities
in an email message.
So we look at things
like, what's the To field,
the From field, and try to find
any anomalous patterns which
will, again, give
us a signal of,
this might be a phishing attack.
We also look for
brand impersonation.
So brand impersonation
would be, for example,
if you have an email
message that contains,
let's say, the logo
of Bank of America
but it's actually not
from Bank of America.
Again, that's a strong
signal that this
may be a phishing attack.
So when we detect
a phishing attack,
we try to do it as early
as possible and reject it
so it doesn't even
get delivered.
Now, what happens-- and
this sometimes does happen.
If we detect a phishing attack
after the message was already
delivered, so when that
happens, what we do,
we go in and reclassify messages
that were already delivered.
So if there's a new attack and
we just found out about it,
we're going to go and
see if this attack is
already present in messages
that were delivered.
And then we'll go
and reclassify it.
And so it will have the
warning that you see there,
that big red warning.
And the links in the message
itself will be disabled.
And by the way, this
is a key difference
in the kind of protection that
you can get from a filtering
gateway solution and what
we at Google can give you,
because a filtering solution has
just one chance to protect you,
and that's when the email
is delivered to your server.
After that, if they discover
something after that,
they cannot go back and
undeliver the message.
We at Google, we can do it
throughout the whole life
cycle of an email message.
Then we have another
last line of detection,
which is Safe Browsing.
So Safe Browsing is
triggered every time
the user clicks a link.
And then the link is
going to be checked
against a database of known
phishing and malware URLs.
And if it's found to be in
the database, then instead
of going to that
web page, the user
is going to be presented with
this kind of warning telling
them that they're about
to do something very risky
and they should not proceed.
Safe Browsing is available
in Chrome as well as
Firefox and Safari.
Now, so we have all these
powerful detection mechanisms,
but you may still ask--
and this is a great
question-- well,
what happens if
something manages
to go through undetected through
all those detection mechanisms?
Because it's an
asymmetric warfare.
The attacker only
has to succeed once
to cause significant damage
to your organization.
So we may be successful 99.9%
of the times, and one attack
can still be a huge damage
to your organization.
So we need some
last line of defense
to protect against the
attack that did go through.
And this is your
line of defense--
the security keys.
So these are
cryptographically secure,
second-factor
authentication which
are not vulnerable to phishing.
They're based on industry
standard FIDO UTF.
They support both USB for
use with laptops and desktops
as well as NFC.
So they can be used
with mobile devices.
And they are secure.
Even if an attacker
gains access,
gains the credential
for an account,
the attacker cannot log into
that account because they need
physical possession
of the security keys.
You actually have to
touch, physically touch,
the security key to gain access.
These keys are simple to use.
And as an organization, you can
enforce the usage of the keys
through the G Suite
admin console.
In Google, everybody
uses security keys.
You have to have
security keys in order
to log into any internal
Google corporate asset.
And it's been working remarkably
well for us at Google.
Let's move onto the
next threat, malware.
So if you've been following
the trends in malware
for the last 10 or 15 years,
you could see a big change
from the first
internet-scale attacks
that we saw in the early 2000s
and the ones that we see today.
The malware of the
early 2000, they
were designed mostly for it
to cause some random damage.
And they were designed
primarily for fast propagation.
So they just want to
spread as fast as possible
before the anti-virus
develops signatures
and can detect and block them.
The ones we're seeing
today are very different.
They're much more sophisticated.
They're financially motivated.
So it's typically
part of a crime ring.
And it can be very profitable.
They're targeted.
There are stealth.
And they use a number
of countermeasures
to avoid detection.
And now I'm going to
ask Nico to walk us
through an example
of such malware
that demonstrates all
the recent trends.
NICO LIDZBORSKI: So we
are going to go today
over the case of Locky malware.
So starting in
February 2016, people
started being targeted
by that malware.
So Locky is ransomware.
It uses encryption to
prevent access to files
until your ransom is paid for.
We estimate that 100 million
people have been targeted
by that particular malware.
It appeared in multiple variants
and auto-released new versions
to counter defenses
that are in place.
So targeting a victim have
been slowly evolving over time.
For instance, the victims
of prior data breaches
[INAUDIBLE] OPM have been
particularly targeted
by that malware
when it came out.
And ransomeware is really a
booming business with profits
in the millions of dollars.
So how does Locky come
up into your inbox?
So it's simply delivered as
a simple email attachment.
It appears here as a simple
invoice in a Word document.
So Locky is using
social engineering
to bypass default security
settings and executing macros.
So with this very advanced text,
it's taking advantage of users.
So the [INAUDIBLE]
here is your protection
is only as strong as
your weakest link.
And the weakest link
is often the user.
So even an attack with a
high level of sophistication
needs social engineering here.
And now Locky is able to run
the next stage of its attack
based on scripting.
So we're going to go into
some of the detail of Locky.
So Locky knows that
modern malware scanners
are using sandbox to monitor
behavior of suspect files.
So sophisticated
malware like Locky
are using tricks to detect
monitoring inside the sandbox.
So here, you can see an example
of what Locky has been doing.
They are keeping track of
time to detect emulation
in a sandbox.
So they start by checking the
time, sleeping for some time.
And sandbox typically
do not really
sleep because people who are
writing sandbox [INAUDIBLE]
be efficient.
They don't want to be
like spinning idlessly.
And then Locky's able
to compute the time
difference and [INAUDIBLE]
it was running in sandbox.
And if it's running
in the sandbox,
it will abort early and not
have any malicious payload.
Now, Locky's also
targeting specific OSes.
So it uses these subtle
difference in script engines
to detect a specific target.
If not on the
appropriate target,
it's going to remain
dormant and avoid detection.
So here you can see
a snippet showing you
how Locky only wants to
use a Microsoft Jscript
interpreter, not JavaScript.
It's just checking
for specific syntax
that only work in JScript
and uses that to move along.
So once a target
has been identified,
Locky moves to the next
stage and really attacks.
It's going to download,
install, and execute
the malicious binary.
Of course, this
was simplification.
The actual payload is
extremely obfuscated
in order to run a lot
of advanced services
to de-obsfucate all the content.
So when the attack
code is executed,
[INAUDIBLE] all user documents
get strongly encrypted.
Locky is using actually
like secure encryption
to ensure all the
payload is locked down.
As a ransomware,
Locky is supported
by a full e-commerce operation.
So they host a
decrypter website on Tor
that are very resilient
and untraceable.
They also ask for ransom
to be paid in bitcoin
to be untraceable.
So now, how are we
tackling malware in Gmail?
So overall, we take
a funnel approach
starting with blank
rejection of common vectors
with known high-risk format
where we actually just blanket
blocking at the
entrance level of Gmail.
And we also have a
diversified approach
that uses multiple file
scanning technologies.
We use internal scanner as
well as external AV partners.
We have intelligent
attachment scanning.
It starts with signature
base, but we support deep
scanning for risky
attachment style.
So risky attachment
get deep scanning,
which means the attachment
actually opens inside a sandbox
environment.
And we monitor
malicious behavior
to detect something
is amok and consider
that piece of software malware
without relying entirely
on signature here.
So we have a real-time
continuous update
on malicious content.
We are also doing rescanning
of content at download time.
So even at the last moment
when you click Download,
it's actually going
to verify again
whether the definition has
been updated since then.
Finally, we also do link
scanning for malware detection.
We are going over
[INAUDIBLE] list of links
that we know are
malicious, and we
prevent them to be downloaded.
So once again, after all the
defenses could potentially
fail, we still
have Safe Browsing
that constantly updates
blacklist of suspicious sites.
So Safe Browsing is taking
care of leftover malware
and phishing that potentially
was not detected earlier.
GILAD GOLAN: Thanks, Nico.
So we covered so far
the three big threats
related to email, which are
spam, phishing and malware.
Now let's move on and talk
about the impersonation
and interception.
And before we talk
about this, it's
important to understand the root
cause that these threats even
exist.
And the root cause is SMTP.
So SMTP, as you may
know, that's the protocol
used to send email
across the internet.
It's one of the earliest
internet protocols.
And SMTP stands for Simple
Mail Transport Protocol.
And as the name
implies, it is simple.
It was designed for a safe
and trusted environment.
Threats were not
taken into account.
And therefore, SMTP, the
original SMTP has no security
mechanisms whatsoever,
which is why
we have to deal with
these threats today.
So what are they?
So impersonation
is when an attacker
sends email appearing to be
from your domain or from one
or some of your domain users.
Interception is when an
attacker gains access
to email content in
transit, typically
by some "man in the middle"
attack, which is important
because SMTP traffic
typically travels
over multiple hops between
source and destination.
And I'll let Nico walk us
through some of the mechanisms
that we have to deal with
interception and impersonation.
NICO LIDZBORSKI: So first
of all, for impersonation
prevention, we rely on industry
standards that add security
on top of SMTP protocol.
All the standards are taking
advantage of DNS record
with a standard domain to
publish security settings
associated with the domain.
So we have SPF, which are
performing authentication
by specifying what
are the email servers
to trust DKIM doing
authentication
using cryptographic
signatures and DMARC,
which establishes a policy on
how to deal with authentication
failures.
Well, first, SPF
is fairly simple.
It's registering the IP
address of mail server
that are authorized to
send mail from a domain.
So here, we have an example
of the policy for a google.com
domain which lists the known
IPs all our outbound gateways.
So we have observed, though,
several shortcomings with SPF.
First, invalid records.
People are putting
invalid records in DNS.
They don't realize that
they don't necessarily
parse correctly.
And they cannot be parsed.
Therefore, we are unable to
make a determination on what
the policy actually means.
The record can also be
white-listing large IP ranges.
And those IP ranges may
fall outside the domain
or allow undesirable
hosts to send emails.
Systems that are sharing public
IP pools with different senders
are also vulnerable
to that type of issue.
Then BGP hijacking
have enabled attackers
to quickly use priorly
white-listed IPs
to send messages.
And finally, DNS records
are very important.
And they can be hijacked, where
the attacker will actually
insert their own IP that
authorizes IPs to send emails.
So DKIM [INAUDIBLE] offering
cryptographic signing of
sent emails using
specific pair domain keys.
So this example
of a message, you
can see the DKIM header,
which is configured
to target specific headers
inside the message that
give message ID, date,
subject, from, to.
So those headers as well
as the body of the message
are in scope for hashing.
So cryptographic
hashing is done.
That has is added as
part of the DKIM record.
And that harsh is signed
using the specific domain key.
Now, how is that
signature verified?
When the email is
received, the DKIM header
includes a selector on which
key to fetch over in DNS.
That key is fetched.
And then it is used to
verify the signature.
So we get cryptographic proof
that the content of the message
hasn't been tampered with.
However, DKIM also
has shortcomings.
It provides strong
improvement over SPF,
but standard is
much more complex.
It requires cryptography
and several libraries
that try to implement
the standard actually
had flaws in it.
They did not verify everything.
So it was actually abused.
Weak keys, like 512
bit [INAUDIBLE],
had been using DKIM.
And attackers have been
able to crack those keys
and generate the private
key associated with it
and are able to sign
on behalf of a domain.
So we don't trust
weak keys anymore.
Private key can also be stolen
from compromised mail server.
So misconfigured server
that allows an attacker
to breach it, the attacker
can steal the DKIM key
and can sign in a
impersonating the domain.
Finally, again,
it relies on DNS.
So hijacked DNS record
have been used in the past
to insert malicious DKIM keys.
DMARC is offering
a policy framework
that defines the action to take
upon failure of DKIM and SPF.
Without it, the
interpretation of DKIM and SPF
is really left to the
recipient's mail server.
So another feature of
DMARC is also reporting.
Reporting allows aggregate
visibility of attempts
to attack a domain.
So we see example for
a google.com record.
You can see the policy
is set to reject
messages failing DKIM and SPF.
It also requires the server
to send an aggregate email
with a list of failures
so the sender domain
impersonated is able to
figure out what's happening.
So we have taken steps to
surface authentication status
to end users.
The goal is really to raise user
awareness of possible phishing
attacks.
We have a fairly clear
visual difference set
between the left side with
an authenticated email that
carries the logo for the
domain, and the right side,
which is not authenticated
with an appropriate symbol.
Overall, we observe a really
steady progress towards better
email authentication.
So non-authenticated email is
now at around 1.8% late 2016,
down from 5.8% two years ago.
Dual authentication
with both SPF and DKIM
is now at like 89.1%, up
from 80.8% two years ago.
So we are really
getting towards a world
where all unauthenticated
messages are really associated
with something very malicious.
Now we'd like to go over
another threat against email
but is interception.
At this point, I'd
like to give you
a quick primer on
35-year-old SMTP protocol.
So in standard SMTP,
client basically
connects to server over TCP
and assemble the email line
by line.
In traditional SMTP, all
that is going over clear text
where server and client just
communicate with each other.
Now, if we look at the
network perspective for this,
the email message is transiting
between Alice's sever and Bob's
sever over the internet.
So an eavesdropper can
trivially intercept any message.
It doesn't have to be active.
It's just passive attacker
just listening over the wire
and be able to see the messages.
SMTP encryption came as
an afterthought in 1999
and was therefore
added as opportunistic,
which means it's best effort.
It requires both client
and server to support it.
In this case, you
can see the beginning
of an SMTP transaction
that supports STARTTLS.
And the sever advertises it's
ability to support STARTTLS.
So the client then establishes
a full TLS connection.
And inside that TLS
connection that's encrypted,
the actual content of the email
can be transmitted securely.
Back to our network
perspective--
so messaging or transiting
over a TLS-encrypted channel
has the consequent eavesdropper
is unable to passively observe
the message content.
So in the last
year, we've really
taken to raise
end user awareness
on the security of communication
of various parties.
So we introduced a broken lock
UI specifically simply showing
to users whenever a
received email was received
over a clear text
connection rather than
a safe, encrypted connection.
With that user
awareness, we have
been able to drive adoption.
Users started to ask senders
why their email were not
encrypted--
starting with their banks.
I received an
email from my bank.
Why is it not encrypted?
So [INAUDIBLE] we saw
incoming email encryption rate
go from the upper 50s to 82%.
So surfacing encryption
status to end user
was enough to put pressure
and drive encryption
use, a very big win
for the internet
because billions more messages
are encrypted every day because
of that [INAUDIBLE].
The current status at
Gmail is of course,
all messages between Gmail
users are encrypted as always.
But 82% of inbound emails from
external senders are encrypted,
and 88% of outbound email
leaving Gmail service
are encrypted.
STARTTLS is not perfect, though.
Email messages can
travel multiple hops
between sender and recipient.
The STARTTLS is only
hop-by-hop protection.
As a consequence, eavesdropper
can still intercept email
if there's an unencrypted hop.
So solution for this
was to actually try
to protect the message
from the sender all
the way to the recipient.
So in January of this year,
we added Hosted S/MIME
support inside Gmail available
G suite enterprise customers.
So S/MIME is an
industry standard
for encrypting and
signing messages
with user-specific keys.
S/MIME is secure, but key
management had traditionally
made it very
difficult to implement
at scale in organizations.
So we've hosted a
S/MIME support in Gmail.
Company's domain administrator
can upload user certificate
and just simply use S/MIME
to sign and encrypt messages
whenever possible and
keep eavesdropper out.
So S/MIME is not just
providing encryption.
It's also signing each
message with the sender's key,
protecting against
impersonation and guarantying
message integrity.
Once rolled out, hosted
S/MIME requires no end user
involvement, which
is a big challenge
with the solution of the past.
End users don't have to
deal with the complexities
of managing certificate
and applying
the encryption themselves.
So now we're going to go
over a different topic, which
is client safety.
Google is constantly
investing in providing you
with the greatest innovation.
And Gmail clients are
taking advantage of this
to provide you with
a safe experience.
So then the email
is based on HTML,
enabling very rich content,
like beautiful image
inside messages.
However, it also
introduces risk.
So we are now going to dive into
some of the innards of Gmail
that are making
this safe for users.
So HTML in email messages is
coming from third parties.
So we don't have control
over third parties.
Therefore, potentially, content
can be potentially broken
or contain unsafe elements.
As a consequence, Gmail team
is walking on state-of-the-art
sanitizer that fixes HTML
and removes unsafe elements.
So in this example
of HTML content,
I highlighted some of the
content that needs to be fixed.
Like an example is the margin
in the case it's invalid,
potentially going negative,
going outside of a window,
and enabling click
hijacking, overriding
some element of the UI.
The bold tag is
not balanced, which
can now allow escaping
outside of HTML content.
The rest of the message
is not balanced as well.
So list should
always be enclosed.
The link URL should
be fully qualified
and go through a redirector,
typically to hide the referrer.
And finally, of course,
we have a script
that should be removed to
prevent [INAUDIBLE] scripting
against your email.
So after going
through sanitization,
the HTML document
has been fixed and is
safe to display
within Gmail clients.
Now, for images,
starting in 2013,
Gmail started proxying
all external images.
So we are doing
this to protect you
from senders who might
try to use images
to compromise the security of
your computer or mobile device.
So all images in
Gmail are loaded
through Google proxy service.
They are delivered to
clients over HTTPS only.
They prevent leaking of
IP address or cookies.
And they also prevent
malicious images formats.
So this, of course, is just
a subset of the security
capabilities we have
been able to provide
to you through our clients.
GILAD GOLAN: Thanks, Nico.
So so far, we talked about
different threats and attack
vectors that come from
outside the organization
and they pose risk
to internal assets.
But think about the
other way around.
Email can also be used
for data exfiltration.
So everybody has
sensitive information
inside the organization.
Email can be used for that
data to leave the organization
and end up in the wrong hands.
And that can be either
negligent or malicious.
So at Google, we provide
DLP, Data Loss Protections,
to prevent such leakage.
And I'm not going to go through
all the different options
that you have in
setting DLP policy.
There's a fairly rich set
of rules and capabilities
that you can define.
This is just one example.
So here, you see
defining a rule.
The rule is going to be applied
to all outbound messages,
anything that leaves
your organization
and goes to somebody
outside the organization.
In this case, the
rule would be applied
to any message that contains
a social security number.
And so in the rules
that we offer,
there is a large number
of pre-defined matches
for sensitive data, such as
social security number, as well
as the ability to define
your own custom matches
for any sensitive data which
is proprietary and unique
to your organization.
As part of the
rule, you can also
define what we should
do when we have a match.
So we can either
modify the message,
reject it, or quarantine it.
So to summarize, so
today, we gave you
a picture of some
of the protections
that we've built around
your usage of email
in Gmail and G Suite.
And this is an area that
is very important for us,
and we're going to
keep investing in that
and improve those protections.
But you have to keep
in mind that this is--
for your domain, this is
a shared responsibility.
We're going to keep
improving those protections,
the mechanism.
But to really keep
your domain safe,
you have to take
advantage of them.
So before we end,
I just want to walk
through some of the
things, some of the actions
that we recommend
that you take in order
to keep your domain safe.
So the first one is
to use security keys
for authentication, for
second-factor authentication.
And I cannot
emphasize this enough.
This is your best
line of protections
against phishing attack.
If you use security
keys and force
that in your organization,
your security posture,
when it comes to
phishing, is going
to be an order of
magnitude better.
Next, so as Nico
described earlier,
SMTP is inherently
not a safe protocol.
So you should set
up DKIM and SPF.
We support both DKIM and
SBF in Gmail and G Suite,
but you have to set it up.
So go to your admin
console and make sure
that it is set up and
properly configured.
And remember-- so
DKIM and SPF is used
to authenticate your email.
So you basically
tell the world, these
are the servers that are allowed
to send email on my behalf,
and this is how I sign email
messages to authenticate
that these really came from me.
Once you set up and configure
DKIM and SPF, the next step,
you should go ahead and
set up a DMARC policy.
A DMARC policy essentially,
after you did the first step
saying, hey, world, this is how
I send email, the next step is
to tell the world,
this is what you should
do if you get email that
appears to come from me
but it fails those
authentication mechanism,
like the signature
doesn't match up.
It's not one of the servers that
I specified in my SPF settings,
what should you do?
So I can tell the world,
if it appears that way,
reject it or report to me,
and this is the email address.
So you can tell the
rest of the world
how to deal with something
that comes from your domain
and fails those security checks.
It's a critical
step to make sure
that your domain doesn't become
a source of phishing and spam
if any machine by one of
your users gets compromised.
The next one is use S/MIME.
S/MIME gives you the best level
of security and encryption
for email messages.
That means every
message is going
to be both signed and encrypted
with a user-specific key,
and it's going to be encrypted
through all the hops it
goes between sending server
and receiving server.
Next, set up DLP rules.
You have it.
It's there.
You just have to set it up.
Every organization
has and deals with
some sensitive information.
That can be social security
number, bank routing numbers,
license driving numbers.
Whatever it is,
make sure, if you
don't want that to
leave the organization
and end up in the wrong
hands, do something about it.
You can monitor it.
You can reject it.
You can set a policy
that enforces it.
And the last one is encourage
users to use safe clients
when they use Gmail.
So as Nico showed you, we
make a tremendous effort
in making sure that we sanitize
the content that we present
to you in our email clients,
whether that's the web
client, or Android, or iOS.
So take advantage of that.
Your users' email
usage is going to be
much safer if they use
these clients than if they
use a third party client.
And last but not least, as
we've seen in the Locky example,
the best security
can be defeated
by exploiting human weaknesses.
So educate your users to
use email responsibly,
avoid risky behaviors,
and pay attention
to all the signals
and the warnings
that we provide to make sure
that your organization stays
safe.
[MUSIC PLAYING]